elle a 17 ans quand ma mère a disparu du mur
un jour elle était là en train de nettoyer et de
préparer le dîner le lendemain elle est partie des
centaines de femmes disparaissent chaque
semaine dites-vous qu'il n'y a rien que nous puissions faire
Je vous recommande d'alerter vos amis vos
voisins ne le faites pas être sur  le guet
ne t'es pas sous sa cre été d'accord je
m'inquiète pour toi Kat c'est trop
à voir avec elle est ce qu'elle te manque non pas
vraiment
tu sais l'époque où j'avais ton âge
ne semble pas trop loin
un [ __ ] de rebelle, bienvenue à l'
étranger
et fini
ouais
et je suppose que tu n'as pas eu de nouvelles de ta
mère ma mère est partie elle ne reviendra jamais
toi